[Music]
my name is Bill burr yeah so where you
guys usually have culture and beautiful
music this really is a beautiful city
although I gotta tell you I I
instagrammed and said that I was here in
Liverpool and the other people are
running one did not have nice things to
say but I think that's based on sports
Heys going to the beatles house is that
like I really I'm at the house like
whether the band played is that really a
stupid touristy thing to do their coven
yeah thing to do because it's Matthew
Street excuse me sir may I interrupt yes
it's not the original no yes no but I
also like gonna cheers in Boston you go
when you think it's gonna look like the
war is it thank you guys I have a
showing especially to get ready for its
rise get used to this shirt I don't know
who makes this shirt this is the
greatest [ __ ] shirt I need donate I
got any ironing I just threw it you wear
it well Thank You Kenny I'm gonna wear
it the hook I watched the bike nine out
of ten days that first European one was
long yeah
it's not gonna like listen Kenny I can
never like live up to your standard of
fashion you know I mean look at you
sweatshirt you trust like Lee Majors on
his do Beinecke man on his day off
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hate sound you know there's
painful just to eat one of these it's
way more painful to hear your derogatory
comments when I sell [ __ ] break shape
right now look at me 50 [ __ ] years
old this you don't see the [ __ ] huh
big keg bellies seeing all these fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] with their crops hey brick
NASA what do you guys have against food
and wonder they went around they try to
conquer everything they're just trying
to get all the spices right what happens
to you when you reach a certain like age
you start crossing your legs I hate how
good this feels
you know there's something about it I
love the way says my name because my
name is only 270 syllables
he has a Twitter session of your
comedian tonight bill burr he always
sounds like surprise like I just met us
I just met him nuts doctor show of the
line I'm gonna have topic he's a real
good friend get Kenny in you I need to
talk to him immediately
[Applause]
just say he was a really good friend I
just met him you just started this
showing a line now goddamn it I built my
entire career that my [ __ ] junk comes
from a place of truth you're right about
integrity
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you Jesus guys that all quiet-like
oh good let's do it
an old-school camera yeah no what are
you gonna do it you can upload that
stole yeah how old's your laptop oh yeah
we got a lot time I like this guy
he's not on the grid if I was a Lamb of
God people in Liverpool do not give a
[ __ ] about polar bear all of that I said
those things can't swim on IRA in this
[ __ ] thing right there little bit
this is six oysters it's like a gallon
of ice
I sworn we're on Matthew Street in
Liverpool this is like allegedly where
the Beatles started whatever they didn't
they moved it
it's like cheers in Boston don't go in
it you're gonna be disappointed
this [ __ ] here we're gonna go down and
check it out this is the ATM that they
used to use Ringo would take out a
couple of pounds and go buy some
drumsticks those crazies you go to
Germany you can still go to the zeppelin
field and stand right where hit Lister
I can stand where Hitler stood and I
can't stand with the [ __ ] Beatles do
[Music]
you think he's like all right say Andrew
wanted to go into the Beatles museum
this is supposed to be John Lennon I was
just like all right this is what the
[ __ ] they all even went to commit look
at the tape
they stole that mannequin from the gap
just slept a bunch of [ __ ] on it to run
less
that is the only thing I've seen here
that is worse than their [ __ ] food I
was just joking with Andrew I was like
you know after three days of eating in
England I now understand why Gordon
Ramsay is so [ __ ] mad all the time
the [ __ ] could you do it dude how bad
were those [ __ ] rice balls oh my god
they're soggy that [ __ ] mama Celeste
pizza dude is just funny be walking this
Italian restaurant and yet this woman
mumble was good as go uh I go is it good
she six I'm believable then I was like
ah [ __ ] I thought they were tourists I
don't understand how you can live this
close to France and Italy and [ __ ] up a
[ __ ] pizza and steak as much as they
do but I'll tell you know what it is
because this is what they they focus all
their [ __ ] on the pub's their pups are
unbelievable there's sports are
unbelievable sense of humor is
unbelievable
fine here's why I already like this
statute is how tall they nation this is
it I feel like I did it
you know sharp dressers I don't let
daily if they have the Michael J Fox
ties on there so he gets the roses cuz
he's the last one who died I was his
birthday Monday okay I swear to God
I struck out so bad with the [ __ ]
fool he takes those oysters right I
thought with food poisoning so anymore
chef this is why you have to [ __ ] eat
and there's business if I call a pound
above 172 that's all I guess Billy fat
tits Billy boobs bag terms of endearment
Billy Seymour Hoffman so Liverpool has a
game tonight they're in first place as
far
[Applause]
tune in the last six years I say Micky
Dolenz goes next he goes with Ringo and
Paul that both walk with vegetarians
I guess it's my fault I brought up a
mass-murderer some reason murdering
something would you rather be murdered
than peed on except I remember that
sensation for the recipe
he's a nice chap a little bit gloomy
gets that look in his eyes every once in
a while just sort of stares at the wall
you know is reliving it
one of my favorite things I learned
about your country is that back in the
day you guys used to wrap the fish and
chips you grasp efficient yesterday's
newspaper cuts and all the grease would
go into the newspaper and the ink would
get on your fish you just [ __ ] cloud
what is that hangover like we got it at
the sports page Trina Hart
the one thing is less violence with your
football games you finally but we
stopped wrapping your fishing ink
Deborah find yourself just rattling off
a [ __ ] story you never read before
[Applause]
enjoy the rest of the tour guys today
the route yeah
one camera camera one phone open the
beautiful tea photos its pastry right
well they're making fun of how [ __ ]
white everybody is here
I look I don't want to blow that place
up
have you know what it is it's I think
there's chicken in there
don't chicken I don't know what this
[ __ ] a river
one of these people on as fat as leo
literally work
welcome terrible
[Applause]